the National Education Union has just
announced two more days of strike action
the Union's executive says as members
will walk out on Wednesday the 5th of
July and Friday the 7th of July in a
dispute overpay and education funding
they've also announced three other
unions are balloting on strike action
and say if their members vote in favor
then all four teaching unions will hold
coordinated walkouts in the autumn well
in a statement the Neu said it is with
Jillian within Jillian Keegan's grasp
for this action to be halted time and
again the National Education Union
alongside his sister unions have called
for the education secretary to get
around the negotiation table to settle
this dispute for a fully funded teacher
pay increase
time and again our calls have fallen on
Stony ground
unlike her counterparts in Scotland and
Wales where the pay disputes have been
settled this education secretary has
willfully turned her back on teachers in
England
no one wants to take strike action but
when faced with an education secretary
who clearly has no interest in settling
this dispute teachers are left with no
option
well in response a government
spokesperson has said further strike
action will cause real damage to pupil
learning and even more disruption for
parents right across the country
thousands of schools are receiving
significant additional funding as part
of the extra two billion pounds of
investment we are providing for both
2023-24 and
2024-25 which will take school funding
to its highest level in history next
year as measured by the IFS
as part of the normal process the
independent school teachers review body
has submitted its recommendations to
government on teacher pay for 2023-24
we will be considering the
recommendations and we'll publish our
response in the usual way